let's go next to our caller from the
to18 area code who's calling today from
to18 hi David it's bill hey Bill what's
up
oh well it's cold hey listen um
what do you think it's gonna take for us
to really honest-to-god get back to a
normal to get out of these dark ages
that we're in right now because you know
the elections it seems like that's just
a bunch of bull you know I don't know
just what do you think it's gonna take I
don't I'm not advocating like for a
revolution but I know that's out of the
question
but like a change in consciousness
people gotta I mean isn't it time
everybody woke up and realized yeah very
very good so listen it's you neither it
sounds like from what you're saying you
are not like a revolutionary leftist I
am also not what would I would consider
a revolutionary leftist I'm a social
democrat so here's the here's the
reality I did a segment about this a
couple of weeks ago it might feel like a
lot of our systems are unsustainable and
if you just draw a line from where we
are now it seems like they would be
medical bankruptcy education cost
inequality it seems unsustainable the
establishment has a way of throwing a
bone every once in a while to keep
people in this middle ground where they
are just okay enough that they're not
going to abandon their job to do the
types of activism that will really
[ __ ] this for the financial system
and force change but still also in a
precarious enough position where they
also really can't afford to do that type
of protesting so like on health care
some bone can be thrown some people
would argue Obamacare was a sort of bone
whatever so as I said before signing
petitions is fine calling members of
Congress is fine voting is more than
fine you've got a vote as a starting
point the system is designed to prevent
people from doing mass rallies at urban
centers and I mean not just people who
already live in the city I mean the
state population masses at the Capitol
demanding change strategic defaults of
mortgages
strategic call-outs to [ __ ] industry
I think that without becoming
revolutionary about it unless and until
we get to that type of activism I think
we will see more of the same of working
around the edges and throwing a bone to
people every once in a while to
basically maintain the status quo for
corporations and rich people I see yeah
I agree with you you know you had a
caller a minute ago from Australia yeah
now there's a country the total
country's on fire and he's down there
saying I can't imagine what it's like to
be in America right now that pretty much
sums it up it's true and at the same
time you know when when we're when the
u.s. is about to get into a war maybe we
have a point of privilege there because
we know the war is not coming here I
mean yes we deal with individual
terrorist attacks domestic most of them
some some foreign but we have a point of
privilege where we can say do we want to
do a war in this country or not without
really having to worry that the war
might actually be on American soil and
that's an extremely privileged position
to be in
I you know I'm a baby boomer too and I
think it's terrible that we have to be
talking just about wars yeah you know
David what do you think about a
candidate like Marianne Williamson who
comes on a platform of pretty much love
I know I realize she doesn't have a
chance you know and I was all for
Marianne at the beginning but now I've
switched over to burning but what do you
think a candidate like or somebody like
Marianne Williamson has a chance to ever
help turn this country around I love her
idea of love I do I also find some of
her new-age pseudoscience beliefs pretty
kooky and last time I mentioned that
people got very mad at me I've
interviewed her on the program before
she has some ideas they're fine but you
know I she's not gonna be the she's not
gonna be elected in 2020 so let's focus
on 2020 first then we can figure out
what kind of a role maybe Mary Ann can
play in the future okay okay David thank
you all right my pleasure great to hear
from you